Các mê ra anh nguy lại cạnh người dan ông được cho là phóng hòa cửa hàng văn phục phẩm ở sá bình đại
khiến của ông tả 122 tuổi mất kẻ bình trong từ vong. Vụ việc xảy ra sáng tảm tháng sấu,
gió cửa hàng chứ như vật liệu dễ trái, lựa nhìn trong lần dọng bao chùm vình trước tân nhà.
Phát hiện trái, nhiều người hô hoán tháo trạy dàng ngoài,
tì nhiên của ông chân ngọc li, tả 122 tuổi, bị thay biến đang ở tân một nên khúc kịp thoát nạn.
Lực lượng trái xấu đó có mặt khó chế hoa hoàn đến hơn 18 mi phút,
lựa cơ bản được kịp suất.
Ông vình văn mây chù tịch, huy bánh nhân dân sá bình đại cho biết,
phần lớn cửa hàng bị thư dùi. Sau khi giập lửa,
lực lượng trức năng phát hiện của li từ vong bên trồng.
Vất đầu nhà trước trách nhi vụ trái xuất pháp từ mộ tấn trân chấp tệ sản,
và trọng ông chân lọc ling, năm 2018, con trái cử li đang bị tạm giữ để làm gió.
Kỳ hàng gió em trái ông liên bốn mấy tám tuổi làm trù.
Người này sống cùng trà là cử li, nguyên nhân vụ trái đang được điều trà.